leave motivation what's the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to man
up love what you do and be courageous
with Dan Pena and my take on his top 50
rules for success volume 2 enjoy okay
let's take it off with rule number 1 man
up all you care guys probably had
bicycles with trainer wheels right on
the little wheels on the side of the
bicycle when you ride it and you didn't
fall off and then when the your parents
took the trainer wheels off what
happened you fell over on your head and
what if your mother probably maybe your
father oh poor baby poor baby and rub
your head when I fell off my bike my dad
hit me just little weenies get up stand
up stop crying oh yeah yeah I mean man
up and now look at me I mean I wish love
got the job done I swear to God I do but
it doesn't
and God doesn't get the job done either
god helps those who help them himself
rule number two love what you do what's
the fun part in your life I'm having fun
right now I love what I do most of you
in this audience don't like what you do
that's what the greatest respect that's
what Michael can help you most of the
people on the 87th Gallup poll did a
survey in 2016
87% of the people on the planet not
counting all the by Afra you know Ghana
Kenya Cana countries 87 percent of the
planet hate what they do they've checked
out they're just taking up time waiting
for retirement I'm sure some of you in
this room getting you know relate to
that 87 percent I've checked out now to
me if you've checked out I mean what the
hell
Jesus and you're all going to live older
the 70 is the new 50 they tell me I
don't even feel 50 I feel 30 I act 30 I
got more energy than part of the whole
room yeah well because I loved dragging
you sorry guys and gals across the goal
line
my wife beloved wife Sally says the
reason I have arthritis in my back is
because you're getting heavy now that
I'm getting older
dragging you across the goal line but I
will kick spit slap I will do whatever
it takes and when I say I'll do whatever
it takes I mean it
I will insult you your mother your
religion I know how to get you to the
top of the podium at the Olympics not
for a bronze medal not for silver before
gold if we're not going for gold don't
waste my time rule number three be
courageous ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls what if you could accomplish in
the world today if you weren't afraid if
you want afraid what people thought of
you said about you whispered about you
what could you accomplish a lot more
you've accomplished today a lot more why
do we care what people think why do we
care what people say and more
importantly why do we care what people
whisper because we have no self-worth we
have a little next to little self-esteem
and we have no self-confidence and how
do we get that way yes mommy and daddy
life expands and contracts with courage
when was the last courage courage type
of thing that you did in your lifetime
walking against the red light whisper
that your spouse your significant other
is a bastard when was the last time you
exhibited some courage some of you have
to go back a long long way
some of you never I said yesterday I
cannot believe that there are people in
this audience that have never been
spanked never had a harsh word said to
them by their parents never got in a
fight on the school grounds I can't
believe that and you wonder why you are
the way you are now I'm not saying that
being a high-performance person is
beating out everybody but it doesn't
hurt rule number four push the envelope
when I was growing up contrary to what
you were growing up I'm 13 years old and
I'm wrestling with lions that's me and
Jackie the line Jackie the line from the
MGM natural Golda Meir that's the first
line of Jackie so I'm not afraid of
animals to this day I'm wrestling my
mother's over here out of camera
screaming and yelling afraid that the
lion is going to eat me and then fast
forward forty fifty years there were
Tigers you can see Sally in the
background there yes people get hurt on
these things yes people get killed on
these things that's why there's only
three people in that picture
and Sally and I went trucking with the
Lions a few years ago because I'm
continuing to push the envelope I never
want to be comfortable doing anything
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-love check out
my 254 series they're free the link to
join her in the description below but
knowing does know initially upfront you
have to try if the swing at the plate a
kid like you if you had to keep track of
seven days a week 24 hours a day what
you do and you want people with a like
mind and it that are better than you
smarter than you more intelligent than
you to get on your bus rule number five
master selling if you're in sales make
300 cold calls a day 300 cold calls a
day 300 cold calls a day correct will it
still work no absolutely we got kids
doing it was a question we even got some
lazy Dutch kids doing it right now just
pick up the phone yeah yeah I mean for
us for a Dutch kid 24 years old to make
twenty cold calls a day you think it's a
big deal there's nobody's teaching sales
in this country that I'm aware of that
tells you that makes 300 cold calls a
day
in fact there's nobody on the planet
that I'm aware of that tells you to make
300 phone calls a day I had a guy just
do a 50 million dollar deal he said Dan
if you just told me I was 2,000 cold
calls away from my first deal I would
have sent you a check for 20 grand and
said thank you and I want to come to the
castle rule number six model success and
life is not a journey it's only if
you're a meathead clubfoot [ __ ] and if
those of you I'm not trying to if some
of you or have issues retardation I'm
not trying to that's not what I'm
talking about that's how I'm talking
about it's a model you find someone as I
said yesterday after we're where he or
she is where you want to be and then you
model them you mimic them you copy them
same way you would if you want to be a
footballer same way you want to be if
you want to be
a golfer you don't copy some monkey that
can't break 100 do you Socrates Plato
Aristotle had this figured out two or
three thousand years ago what happened
why did we stop these are arguably the
first mentor-mentee relationships that
were existed on the planet I'm not
teaching anything new guys gals I give
credit to the man that I copied Andrew
Carnegie came up with the qlae Marlin
didn't call qlae because he was a he
could have been Dutch really he was a
meat mean cheap person that didn't want
to spend money so he didn't allow equity
in his transactions he only used depth
as you would say dad so he would still
own it all and that's all I did he was
doing this 140 years ago what I do rule
number seven have a dream but if you
believe if you believe in yourself I had
to go up Obama again Obama I had a dream
I'm running down Torrance Boulevard in
1983 and I had just looked at a magazine
called the rob report which I recommend
that you all subscribe to and it had
castles on islands in the and I said I'm
gonna buy a castle on an island that was
March 83 I moved into the Guthrie castle
September 1 84 had no way to pay for it
didn't have up more I had a pot to piss
in
but 15 months later was that 15 or 17
months anyway from March to September 1
the next year so I had an Obama moment
and I wasn't even cracked up
I had a dream so even though I make fun
of these guys that have a dream but I've
had it myself but if you don't have a
dream guess what it can't come true and
you're never going to exceed your
highest expectation you will never for
those of you that want to make a million
dollars you're never going to make a
million in one rule number eight
surround yourself with greatness what
can you do to build self-confidence and
self-esteem you are who you hang around
with show me your friends and I'll show
you your future show me your friends and
I'll show you your future
the first self-esteem is built the first
seven or eight years of life who are you
around for seven or eight years of life
mom maybe dad older brother uncle a
grandmother right what the hell do they
know about building self-esteem they
don't know anything and now show me your
friends I'll show your future who do you
go hang with put a shield with and I
anti and he he and I we disagree about a
few things but Bill Gates doesn't hang
Steve Jobs who I knew didn't chill
Warren Buffett doesn't hang a Elon Musk
doesn't hang and I go down the list the
people that don't hang very few people
are happy with what they're doing and if
you want to build self-esteem deal with
people that have high self esteem rule
number nine impact lots of people for
those of you that want to save the world
go make a bunch of money and then go
save the world or more recently the last
four or five six years I've said figure
out a system a process a procedure an
invention that changes a billion lives
and you'll become you know most I've
been in there
ie Facebook Zuckerberg rule number ten
hold yourself accountable this young kid
he came to me a year and a half ago his
goal is dreaming his life was finished
number one University champion Archer in
Britain what's the best you've ever done
20th in a regional meet he said to me so
we set up a program and I beat him like
us
mule that's him receiving the first
place a couple months ago in Britain the
little skinny he looks like a little
nimrod snowflake to the years but he was
firing six seven hundred arrows a day
most of you couldn't fire fifty most in
you in this room have never been held
accountable about anything in your life
and look at the result real number
eleven focus focus focus I focus on
everything I mean I focus on one thing
at a time most of you are engaged in two
or three or four different endeavors and
you're not doing any of them very well
focus on one and I never get in a
business I'm not looking to exit but by
the way I said it yesterday for those of
you and I've read some emails from a
couple of you you have a business that
two years ago and now you're doing two
hundred fifty thousand or two hundred
sixty thousand euros in revenue that's
geometric growth you started from zero
twenty four months ago you're now doing
two hundred and fifty thousand euros
that's geometric growth but now what did
I say yesterday you started playing not
to lose instead of playing to win focus
I mean and it's it's it's a single key
thing when you're an athlete I was an
athlete by any stretch of the
imagination but the world-class athletes
I've had the privilege of working with
all the same thing focus if they're
basketball players and I had a pleasure
of working with the Lakers back in their
heyday they wake up they go to sleep in
the basketball literally football is
they go to sleep I mean from the time
they get up to the time they go to bed
that's all they think about its focus
rule number 12 expose yourself to
high-performance people I had a nursery
mother but I had a dad that kicked the
[ __ ] out of me beat me like a rented
mule
and if my father were still alive and I
have uncles and they say Manny you're
too hard on Danny and he would say just
as he looked into the camera and said my
son success well not because I'm even in
spite of me
he looked them in the eye and says how's
your program working out with your
crackhead poor daughter because when
they compared me no matter how much I
did wrong my success I don't know
anything other than dropping the ball in
center field which I have nightmares
about to this day I've only had success
and when you've only had success all
your life I make money by accident
I don't know failure I just don't and
it's infectious and you start not
hanging our children exposing and not
exposing yourself in a sexual way
exposing your shy gotta be careful about
all these words up and you start
exposing yourself to high performance
people I mean and you will forget how to
be a loser you'll forget how to be a
loser number thirteen don't care what
others say some people will never like
me and I will never give up you worry
about what they say as I told Brian Rose
many years four years ago if you have no
idea how limitless your life becomes
visibly goals when you don't give a [ __ ]
what people think say or whisper about
you you have no idea the world will not
value me until I value myself and the
reason why people don't value kids it's
because you don't value yourself
companies is not they will like be
confidences I'll be fine if they don't
like me now it's safe to say that I've
never been worried about what people
think of me that's a truth that's a
truth rule number 14 go big Jeff it's
working about 150 billion dollars the
founder of Amazon this is what he looked
like almost 20 years ago
twenty years ago they laughed at him
twenty years ago here it wasn't worth
$20,000 let alone 150 billion now he's
got to come a company roughly speaking
around a trillion dollars little less
maybe 150 billion less because of the
sell-off in the market etc but they
laughed it and he had an idea he had a
dream like him I had a dream about 35
years ago I am the first person on a
planet
it took an option or something he did
not own on a major Stock Exchange I'm
gonna say okay I don't own that book
right
I paid him a dollar out of a national TV
$5.00 for that book
I hear from now I took an option I took
that but not owning it and I sold it on
the new york stock exchange for 150
million bucks that's what i did and that
was the beginning of my quantum leap he
number 15 work hard when I first went
worked for Wall Street firm in 1972 the
they didn't really have any formal sales
program training programs and so what
they did is they they give you the
yellow pages call everybody in the
yellow pages and when you got through
the yellow pages call everybody in the
white pages and then when you got down
for the white pages you called you co
called every building that had more than
ten stories on Wall Street well every
building on Wall Street has ten stories
and so you got to kiss a lot of frogs
paying you before you're going to find a
customer
and you got to turn over a lot of rocks
there was 25 years straight from 1991 to
1996 I didn't take a day off
25 years straight 1991 for 71 to 1996 71
denied I didn't take a day off
rule number 16 believe two months ago
when we were working I signed a deal for
a TV show a few weeks ago and they were
doing research and we discovered that
where I lived 1972 on 27th and Lexington
when I first went to Wall Street so
we're now been torn down leads to called
the building the bedbug probably some of
you live in the bedbug now and then 12
years later I was living in the castle
12 years yes was a castle on my my
affirmations yes was a castle on my gold
yes was a castle in my prayers yes but I
thought the castle was gonna have a moat
and have all kind of neat stuff doesn't
have a moat but it's pretty neat place
for those of you look at Google because
I could continue to believe I continue
to believe so I've gone from the body oh
that's where my house used to be behind
that chain-link fence and you can see
between me and that brick wall isn't
very much space we had 800 square foot
house I think that's 75 square meter
house even some of you probably live in
bigger houses than that and of course
there I am with my lovely wife on my
75th birthday I needed a new rolls-royce
like I needed aids so what did my wife
gave me for my 75th birthday a role just
like the Queen has so when we drive I go
just like she does me number 17 surround
yourself with rich people so you've got
rich people right most of you aren't
hanging not chilling for those people
are you nope why you've got all kind of
reasons why don't you I didn't go to
school but that's what I gotta say about
all those reasons I didn't either but
somehow I weaseled my way into people
richer than that in a good way because
it was important to me to change my life
from being a barrio bad boy who almost
killed his teacher when he was 12 years
old
if success was important you would have
done something about it by now but it's
not too late it's never too late
rule number 18 don't let failure stop
you success is like being pregnant
everyone says congratulations but nobody
knows how many times you go you have
three million pores in your body
three million I've been in every one of
them at least twice in a bad way I have
a young mentee in the room who just
recently got his first and I'm not
making light of rape and like it but
basically recently almost got his first
financial raping here recently and I
have a lot of scar tissue because you
know if I allow people who disappoint me
I'd never get it out of bed in the
morning
rule number 19 keep yourself in shape
energy is in here I happen to be an
excellent physical condition not if I'm
72 if I'm 32 I'm in an excellent state
but I work at it and I have worked at it
since 1974 what is now called biohacking
I started being aware of my physical
condition I test my blood every six to
eight weeks I've got you know I told you
yesterday I wasn't joking about my
testosterone level the but I work at it
and but when I turned 60 I only drink
when I'm traveling now or at the
seminars I don't drink and I'm a vegan
than when I'm at home not because I
believe in that because horse but it
lose weight like crazy when you're a
vegan
rule number 20 be obsessed when I was in
Poland as I said last yesterday
afternoon I talked about some very
successful kids and I said yawn stand up
he's 22 years old he's currently a
student at a crack out of university he
made a million euros last year which is
no big deal to me but to most you a
million euros is a big deal
now one single student went up to ask
him what his name was yawn what because
if they did and he told them the tip the
secret the secret sauce they
they feel some responsibility to try to
do it themselves and then when they
failed then you know most of the
podcasts most of the seminars most of
the various things that you study you're
not learning
otherwise why you're still here
with the greatest respect of Michael
there's no reason when you leave here
today after the Q&A is over and I've
already told you everything's free on my
website I don't and when you see me in
the airport don't come up and talk to me
don't touch me I don't give a [ __ ] if
you live or die my obsession is to drive
as many of you lazy bastards across the
goal-line it's humanly possible before I
die that's it if I have to hurt you spit
on you call your mother a [ __ ] I don't
care rule number 21 commit fully when
Josh was uh he had a sixty hour a week
job and he was doing kill a 70 hours a
week that doesn't get much room for
sleep does it but you say well he was 17
18 you don't need sleep when you're 17
18 you will already we already got a
reason why he you can't work 130 40
hours a week that you need sleep
he cut back the three hours a night's
sleep the guy who just listened to and
then he couldn't take it he only lasted
a few weeks at three hours a night's
sleep and so he had to go back to four
hours when you know it's like when you
were in lust with that person you know
you wanted a call knife and the toilet
in the car in the closet or your app
when you when you figure out that every
hour you sleep you're not making money
you'll never sleep again real number 22
focus on making money now money's not
everything it's the only thing anybody
keeps track of but it's not everything
but for those of you who want to save
the world
go find a product an idea that will
change opinion lives and by definition
one you'll save the world and two you'll
be a billionaire because you see gates
and Buffett and a number of the
Illuminati's that have made a lot a lot
of money in current day they've made a
lot of money now they're trying to save
the world
Bill Gates wasn't running around with a
placard as they say in this country
around the embassy about save the
rainforest when it was 17 18 20 years
old and we have some save the world guys
in the gut in the audience and we have
save the world guys in every audience
rule number 23 master sales our children
finish undergraduate school and they
both work before they went on to
graduate school I told both Kelly and
Derek makes 300 cold calls a day and
you'll lead the nation in sales or in
anything you do 300 cold calls a day and
that's getting through to somebody not
leaving a message web Evette and they
both did you cannot even if you're a
[ __ ] like you guys if you make 300
legitimate cold calls you'll make a
million dollars a year no problem and
that's not a lot of money and I say that
begrudgingly but to most people it is
that's 12 that's 1,500 cold calls a week
that's 6,000 cold calls a month that's
72,000 cold calls a year if you can't
make a minion out you ought to kill
yourself metaphorically speaking we
number 24 be selfish I tell the kids
you're gonna hear something here that
you not hear you haven't heard what
going up I want you to be more selfish
to fulfill your dreams and for those
people that are getting in the way of
your dreams
the don't be more selfish to them just
extract them from your life mmm it's a
lot easier and my first wife or what my
current wife for Oh for many years we're
here to tell you they'd say we worship
the ground an walks on but nobody loves
Dan more than Dan mm-hmm my love for my
husband is transitory compared to his
love for himself nobody loves me more
than me and that's how you be the best
husband the best student the best father
the best brother the best grandchild the
best citizen in my judgment is love of
yourself of course that's self-esteem
that's self-confidence number 25 have
tough skin when you think about what
other people think say about jet cetera
but we really haven't dwelled on because
it's a waste of time how much time you
waste worrying and of course you worry
because you have thin skin a car
Adenauer the former mayor of Berlin said
the thick skin was a gift from God
thick skin it was a politician very
successful politician and the Sally
calls me Rhino skin because it takes
it's true I mean I can't remember the
last time that somebody said something
that well I can't ever remember since
I'm a kid somebody Saints them that hurt
me I mean hurt my feelings I I just I
think back about it you know and I can't
I can't remember and I'm sure everybody
in this room can remember somebody
saying something about them that hurt
your feelings I can't remember and you
can remember because
I just you know I wasn't raised that way
we limit 26 follow your heart if you
want we'll go back how much did you what
I don't know I want to become wealthy
well I mean it's easier to become
wealthy here than in Romania although we
have Romanian mentees millionaires we do
but it's harder here it's eating them
it's not easy easy
but Lithuania Hungary Romania those
countries it's harder oh the best deal
in 25 years was just done by one of my
Hungarian mentees and he just did the
second best deal in 25 years on top of
that deal and he's a little Peter if
you're listening I mean I mean he didn't
have enough self-confidence to brush his
own teeth I mean and now he's a wealthy
guy on the cover of Hungarian business
and he did it without paying one bribe
and that's a big deal know that part of
the world so but I mean you got to
follow your heart I don't mean a lovey
gushy way for your mom I mean you got to
follow your life because at 25 years
from now your mother's gonna be dead and
you're gonna regret that you spent any
time with her yeah I'm in the regret
minimization business what are you going
to tell your grandkids during the
greatest transformation of wealth and
they history the planet what were you
doing other than having a thumb up your
ass
rule number 27 be a firm leader be firm
but fair but firm because people
appreciate they're there the kids don't
lack ingenuity what they lack is
leadership and now being a firm leader
it's considered politically incorrect
showing tough love they forget the tough
part they only ever remember the love
part look you recommend a tough-minded
management correct right Joe Maddon John
yeah it's still a very relevant book it
is Joe Maddon was the mentor of Ross
Perot a billionaire back in the day and
he also wrote a my principles I think
yeah yeah that's a
my life in my principal yeah not many
people read it because they don't have
very poor now no any also wrote a book
to find a leadership yeah and those are
the only two books you need on
management and leadership
rule number 28 be hard our kids were
here right now my daughter would say
Jesus guy
the world is stepdad for another reason
though why anybody would want to be
raised by you you have no idea what it
was to be your child I'm sure I don't I
don't and my daughter as I think I
mentioned yesterday my dad treats
everybody the same like and I'm hard and
hard works world-class coaches are hard
we have a bug on the Hall of Fame my
most successful mentees he says I
haven't been beat this hard since I was
the number two guy on the Austrian ski
team arguably one of the best ski teams
in the world and then he blew out his
knee and his coaches to beat him I mean
physically beat him now I can't get away
with that anymore but the most even
needed a beat and growing up you just
did and most of you your parents your
parents weren't weren't trained to
produce high-performance kids you and I
both know it you and I both know it
we've had Hut we've had grandfather's
daughters granddaughters we've had sons
and fathers in the seminar room and when
you ask the grandfather I did the best
we know now ask the mother you don't
know what you don't know ask the kid yep
you don't know what your kids will you
think about you I do I get their emails
most of your kids are embarrassed by you
in some cases I'm sorry to say ashamed
of you
rule number 29 get in the right business
I'm 31 I love my own business we make
about a hundred and twenty grand a year
give or take which i think is very low
I have another idea I might I might do
which I think could make maybe a million
but am I just shy just abort everything
and just Wow most of you that have
businesses in the room if you go home
and turn the key does everybody
understand that
close them down don't open up Monday I
could say that I don't even have to look
at your numbers turn the key adios
something new because most of you are
living quiet lives of desperation
most of you are living hand-to-mouth
paycheck to paycheck that's a hell of an
existence I used to be there believe me
I know what that feels like you know and
but if you're not in a big margin
low-hanging fruits if you're not in the
new economy if you're not in health care
if you're not in telco if you're not in
cybersecurity if you're not in radiology
if you're not in the things that
building infrastructure building roads
building bridges you're just Jim as what
book metaphorically you might as well
just blow your brains out because Sally
she says goddamn it Dan you said
remember what the lawyers told us so no
the lawyers you know real number 30
improve your communication skills people
were the best communication skills do
best at this and most of your
communications go suck most of the ditch
retards I don't mean [ __ ] in that
sense retards watching us in YouTube
have no communication skills at one time
I had piss-poor communication skills
they used to throw plates at me when I
talk go to a Rotary Club to give a
speech can you place at me your feelings
would be hurt
remember 31 master communication skills
you you if you can't sell your dream
nobody's going to join you Oprah
Winfrey's got a saying about you know
it's not a
exactly important where the bus is going
but the people that you have on the bus
with you because you're gonna morph
you're going to pivot which is true and
if you are not enthusiastic
overwhelmingly enthusiastic that's not
been one of my shortcomings I've always
been enthusiastic and and I've had the
good the great communication skills and
the but you don't have if you if your
communication skills are five percent of
mine we have no problem being a
billionaire five percent of mine five
percent and that's why I tell you go to
improv go to Toastmasters etc I got a F
and public speaking in high school I got
an F in public speaking in university
and I got a D in public speaking the
second time in university but then I
went to made to 250 speeches where I
told you and then some of you don't
believe me they threw plates at me
they threw dinner rolls at me but I
didn't leave the podium
I am tied out auditoriums my speaking
skills were so poor me number 32 don't
care what others think like the world
has become sophisticated political
correctness range and I'm here about me
that political correctness is the
manifestation of lack of self esteem
because you care about what people say
about me you care about what people
think about you and I got and either
this Jeff Bebo's Bill Gates Warren
Buffett Elon Musk Henry Ford the first
and I go down with rule number 33 play
to win I want to open hundreds of salons
around the United States even in Europe
my problem is how do I find a team I can
trust how do I find a good team and
that's what I'm having you don't find a
team by not taking action you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes that's just the
way it is the more you question it the
less you're going to be inclined to pull
a trigger I would rather make a mistake
then just think about making a mistake
say you're so afraid you're you so used
to playing not to win and play not to
lose Lima 34 always keep practicing just
like the astronauts the astronauts are
trained for years and years and years
before they go up for every contingency
for every single possibility and some of
the possibilities are one in a trillion
but they still train for him practice
practice practice the people that are
doing the most and Joshi alluded to it
himself he practices it's very easy to
get sloppy after you've done a bunch of
deals I practice between one and one and
a half hours for this seminar for every
app before the seminar
I had in about 7080 hours in the
seminars fifty hours long 78 75 80 hours
that I practice and I know what's on the
slide 11 58
and then you know sometimes I skip to
2030 sighs and I I did skip because we
had already gone over this stuff last
night when I was working and the because
we're going to talk about goals now and
and if you don't see your vision
Bill Gates I'm told although I never
asked him he saw a computer in every
house okay and I told you yesterday he
now was yours he said he put two
computers in every house and most houses
do have to write some have three four
five and then he said I should have said
a computer every I said on the entire
planet but they all practice there's a
slide coming up and showing Hitler
practice practicing when he was
practicing before he became Chancellor
in 1933 I think it was maybe 32 I he had
over a million pictures taken of him a
million in the right pose the right
there's the right hand gesture yesterday
the right so he could be more effective
he studied great speakers before him and
arguably uh mr. Hitler even though he
was an ass all he was one when the great
orator of all time with over 35 use
storytelling I think people realize that
how Greg you are the communicator and
I'm always very like shocked there how
good you are even as a storyteller how
great your memory is there you'll be the
tell story how do you do that well I
work at it when I first started I didn't
have any stories yes I only had the
stories of my mentors yeah okay and some
do man yeah Jim Newman Kosta carrasco's
who was CEO of an acid shipping and a
guy named Jerry Ormond who is my mentor
in the oil business and so but over time
I learned by storing around meaning
people will
allow information to resonate into their
subconscious when they hear it in a
story form and so when I saw that my
mentors used stories and they were
pulling stuff from 20 30 years ago that
resonated with me and so then I
developed my storytelling abilities and
I and I tried to frame everything I did
in a story and a true story and now the
the occasionally I'll miss a date and
somebody from the internet will correct
me no it wasn't in 2001 it was 2002
that's fine at least I have a backstop
yeah but I'm only off a year and I've
got a million stories so give me a break
you do yeah but I realize how much they
work and now I have stories that I can
tell about you yes I have stories I can
tell about you know Brian rose I wrote I
have stories about many many other
successful kids and and that resonates
even more with the kids
rule number thirty-six be willing to
break some eggs as soon as we got
tougher as soon as we got less PC as
soon as we got that we didn't care what
they said or thought about us we got
more successful and we started doing
deals
we started doing deals you cannot do you
know a lot of transactions without
hurting feelings you know the old saying
about to make an omelet you gotta break
eggs you know and everybody that's ever
had an omelet there's normally some kind
of eggshell in it because they can't get
all the eggshell out
collateral damage Fred Smith the founder
of Federal Express said he's similar
background similar age he was a young
marina officer I wasn't robbery officer
he said when he came back from Vietnam
as soon as he realized his mistakes the
collateral damage of his mistakes did
not end up with body bags
meaning dead people he says the rest was
easy so the worst I was ever going to do
is hurt somebody's feelings make him cry
and he built Federal Express and he's
one of the icons of business who's still
running them business rule number 37 be
tough in theory we should be able to
kill off the Russians easy but we won't
kill up the resin because they're tough
they're tough now when I went through
Ranger School they hung us from trees
and put battery wires on artistical 's
there dozens and hundreds of lawsuits
against the federal government because
the guys couldn't have kids they take us
out on anthills and pour honey overs and
let the ants eat is for two or three
days this was a training
and now and you're right I mean when the
spirit of the beignet used to be to kill
and you're going through a boot camp you
know many a broken tooth cracked jaw
because your drill sergeant hit you in
the face with the butt of the rifle and
no you wonder why we're all concerned
that's why I bring my own security okay
I happen I'm not ignoring you and a
Toronto if somebody finally asked me why
did you bring the cricket bat snowflake
I said because they your school told me
I should have security which they did
I'm not gonna pay a bunch of goons no I
can do the same as they can't and I said
and what and then there's somebody asked
me about 20 minutes what do you do with
a cricket bat I swore to you and then I
jumped down off the stage
and I said because the first five or six
if you aren't going to come at me even
though that's 400 of you because you
don't want to be the first one two or
three that I knocked their head off but
they had to ask me what I was gonna do
with a cricket bat that's enough that's
where we are
rule number 38 don't give in programming
you're yourself and your habits really
isn't that difficult when you understand
what makes the synapses fire it's not
it's not that hard but you're not used
to saying no you're used to saying yes
or not saying anything and giving tacit
approval how many times for those of you
they have a significant other there's a
significant other say something you know
just [ __ ]
you just give in make peace why make
more right I don't fall into that
category and if you're used to saying
yes just to not make war or you're used
to giving tacit approval just not to
make more at home that follows you in
the rest of your life
I follow soon the rest your life and but
once you get used to it
like most spouses significant others
will say god he's changed she's changed
most will say for the worse until you
get traction them till you get momentum
oh god I like the new roles I night I
like to do this I like plan first class
Dan's a genius now but that takes some
time
let's take some time renumber 39 model
success success leaves clues if you know
all you know if successful if the super
successful people don't hang chill chill
don't go to Super Bowls and all those
things and the hard asses okay but only
90 percent of the high performers in the
world or alpha males 2% or alpha males
98 percent of regular people
because for example Elon Musk Zuckerberg
Warren Buffett all share one attribute
they're introverts this out continuum
correct yeah and so I mean you don't
have to be an alpha male and back in the
day a hundred years ago and doing
research for one of my talks they had
obviously alpha males but they didn't
call them alpha males they call them oak
trees oak tree oak trees because that
was considered the straightest thing in
the forest and it didn't break down and
so they were called oak trees and the
but when I tell people about Zuckerberg
Elon Musk Warren Buffett all being
introverts because most people are
introverts most people are pleasers rule
number forty find your drive
what drives you did well when I went
into coaching twenty-five and a half
years ago I wanted to change what was
called personal development then and the
true financial coaching stroke mentoring
and I didn't know what I would have to
do
but whatever I've done in my life I
always want to lead I want to be first
so after about four or five years I
discovered that I even though I'm a good
motivating motivational speaker that's
not what I want to do I want to teach
how to create generational wealth okay
well if that normally takes 20 to 25
years to create which is the definition
of a generation in three to seven years
as we were saying in the car on the way
over here three years if you do
everything perfectly which we know
nobody does it perfectly go six or seven
years for somebody that's good and eight
to ten years if you're a real doofus and
I realized the work that it would take
and that I sold all my portfolio I sold
all my assets Sally and I have been in
cash for a long long time because I
don't want there to be a conflict
between me giving the kid advice and my
own personal investment strategy and so
the as we've continued developed the
templates the processes the systems and
the procedures they're based on success
one success after another success last
four or five years we've produced
teenage multi millionaires some of the
teenage multi millionaires as you can
witness on YouTube are flying around
their own goddamn jet planes now we
we've produced the largest deal in
recorded history the five hundred
billion dollar neon which is the ascent
city of the 22nd or 23rd century with a
man T Klaus Kleinfeld so we've got
everything from millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions billions
tens of billions and even hundreds of
billions now and we have all the systems
how to do it and 99.9% of all the kids
that have benefited from qlae I've never
met I would know him if they were
standing in this room because we decided
almost ten years ago to give all the
product away free because I went as you
pointed out I went to the most expensive
products online
yeah to free yes because that takes away
almost all the excuses of the kids
they're just flapping their mouths
rule number 41 be different difference
between a victim and victory is action
most of you and most of the people on
the YouTube have led choir wise of
desperation
and they've liberalizes victims just as
your parents have it just could be
parents or a doctor or a lawyer or
doesn't make a you know that's an
honorable profession I'm not discounted
I mean being a schoolteacher is an
honorable profession being a plumber is
an honorable profession
you wanna you want to create generation
or well change the lives of a billion
people
none of your ideas in this room are
changing lives of a million people let
alone billion Zuckerberg is the most
classic recent example of that God knows
he's changed the lives of three and a
half billion I'm not just here for the
best but that's a whole other story but
I mean you know if you're not first we
got to be different your ideas what's
your unique selling proposition what's
your barrier to entry all these things
that you know when I look at your deals
and I'm not even town that deals these
[ __ ] on YouTube Jimmy I've forget
about that but I mean you has anybody
ever thought this through and the course
is in the podcast and the web doesn't
anybody ever talk about Barry to aintry
if you're not first we've got to be
different does anybody talk about that
no we never 40 to go big it doesn't
register that you can make 10 million
dollars in a day I remember the first
day I made $10,000 October the 5th 1974
I remember the first day I made $100,000
1976 I remember the first day I made a
million dollars to me okay I remember
the first day I made 10 million dollars
and I remember like when I took a this
morning and brush my teeth the day I
made a hundred million pounds and one
day me without question your goals are
too low and they're too low why mommy
and daddy who probably had no goals you
know my dad my parents only had one goal
in life to keep me alive until I reach
the age of reason
that's it there wasn't any because I was
a they used to call a problem child back
in those days I don't you know but I was
a tear to say the least
ruler 43 don't rely on business plans
with a slider dude pile of crap five or
six lines ago and most of what you've
learned today about creating
generational wealth being an
entrepreneur starting a business
I heard somebody say earlier about a
business plan business plans are passe
they're not needed I'll explain it later
why they're not me
these are the business plans it's a wild
ass yes I've never seen in 50 years of
doing this a business plan fail on paper
I'm gonna say that guys I'm insane yeah
I've never seen a business plan fail on
paper
why because you put the most optimistic
in there right so who's gonna believe a
business plan only morons that's why
they're not needed
rule number 44 play to win if you've
started the business the first 50,000
pounds euros or dollars in your business
with geometric growth quantum leap the
next 50 or 100 thousand dollars or
pounds or euros was geometric growth
then what happened
you started playing not to lose instead
of playing to win you sat on your assets
like a mother hen and we're afraid that
you're going to lose the money that you
made anybody that's gone from zero to a
hundred thousand zero to ten thousand
has created geometric growth some of you
sorry [ __ ] in this room have which is
hard to believe shows goes to show any
person can do it even brain-dead retards
like you
the first dollar did you make euro pound
is geometric growth you retards
then why didn't you continue rule number
45 use fear to your advantage I know
fear works and I'm a proponent of it
and anybody thinks any different is
crazy foolish I don't know we're at the
right terminology here still works just
in athletics today you University of
Central Florida who won one of the
national championships in football last
year the fear of not making the team
they use to recruit because they were
the one of the two national champions
and the other whoever the other one was
the fear of getting cut from the team in
athletics the fear of not making the
Olympic team
getting good enough grades to get into
Harvard where with a you know you want
to go to school
but they they couch it differently now
they don't call it fear they call it
motivation but motivation to fear works
rule number 46 find your true path well
a young second lieutenant and I wanted
to go further I know they didn't have
office clubs anymore but in those days
they did I go to the old club and
everybody's drinking and I said what for
fine without drinking which is Dave
inherited one meeting for $9,000 I never
heard that before I didn't know how many
zeros was in a meeting I'm not lying
so I said could you write one big
important that my own app component you
get I said well this is rigged up right
so again a few weeks later I get an
award and I'm being the award there
that's two star general Woodrow Vaughn
retired three-star general West Point
guy and he said I got an award I came up
with an idea to save the army two
million dollars by asking that
commitment to give me a $50 more var
this how come enough today 50 out of the
world there were 6,000 75 cents when
they gave it to me I say too many
dollars they need $6.75
okay you can be warned
well I have already report to director
one-star general another West Point kid
so for the O club general a degrees on
the side of the journal bonds on the
side a I'm a first lieutenant by this
time and they said Danny you oughta buy
his drinks why's that well first of all
if you start Daniel comes be a first
lieutenant you start by doing that right
and so I said but why Denison you one
that that award and I still it's only
one 6075 sent down again he said the
magic words Danny a young boy like you
in the civilian world would be rich and
a light bulb went off in my head I can
still remember the moment a light bulb I
was in to be a regular army officer I
like the military I loved it I love
money
civilian like I was out of the army six
months six months and one week later I'm
out to stalk a lot of people from a five
percenter young hard charger you
probably got some of the guy the young
heart Chargers young junior officers
here at the Naval Academy draw him out
and six months in one week and the world
has been my horse to everything is neat
number forty-seven love what you do
every day I get stronger every day in
the summer you get weaker why do you
think that is because I love what I do
and you hate what you do there's a slide
coming up tomorrow Gallup poll in 2016
eighty-seven percent eighty seven point
seven percent of the people on the world
hate their lives 87 percent hate their
lives I'd like to find a 13 percent I am
found too many of those but they say
they're around
meaning the 48 stop giving tacit
approval most of you have lived your
lives and your parents lives giving
tacit approval
tacit approval is the reason why you're
here today and the people are on YouTube
are poor on YouTube we casted approvals
this this guy tells me something and I
know it's horse I just didn't listen and
then I'm walk away right or god forbid
and I hear his [ __ ] and I happen to
nod my head okay now he goes so there's
other muttonhead over here and he says
Dan's on board
not because I said I was on board or by
action and I nodded my head up and down
because I didn't say I wasn't on board
in his mind I've given him passed it
approval you've lived your whole lives
for those of you that work in big
organizations you listen to your boss
you know he's foolish but you just sit
there and listen now I got in trouble
Isis in your foolish that's [ __ ] all
my life and I told you dr. Shirley
Teeter said the only thing that's
changed with Danny Pena is that his
accomplishments have caught up with his
big mouth renumber 49 don't show
weaknesses the thing that always amuses
me is that the current day movies except
there at the end of the movie normally
the day that people reconcile that's not
my experience the higher perform
or the higher the performance person the
less probability that they're gonna
reconcile with anybody why because they
don't need anybody
and almost all the big hitters
no in President Trump is a primary
example of this a preeminent example
saying sorry is a weakness
the weakness saying you were wrong was a
weakness what do I say I may be wrong
but I'm never in doubt every I know
which flies in the face of all the bush
now
president Trump doubles down triples
down I don't know if you can quadruple
down but and that's my experience with
those guys and the few really
high-powered women that I've known
so again it flies in the face of
virtually everything you've been taught
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is surround
yourself with success when I first read
Think and Grow Rich in 7 1972 I think I
underlined it and then I didn't read it
again so I believe in the early 80s and
I had the same copy of the underlined
and I went back and was interesting when
I underlined in 72 as opposed to what I
underlined in 82 and then when I read it
again in about 2003 for the things that
I underlined the first time I said Maya
how come I didn't understand that the
person I mean that's so simple and most
of the stuff that I underlined the
second time exists it was a slam dunk
and so because I had grown and matured
not just because you know the mayor of
the frontal lobe of the brought a male
brand isn't finished maturing or growing
into 26 27 or 28 the frontal lobe the
frontal lobe of the female brain is
mature way before that way before that
and the and so when I was even though I
was pretty successful in my mid-20s the
mostly by design some by serendipity but
most of my success was because I was
around successful people and I didn't
understand you you are who you hang
around with show me your friends and
I'll show you future I didn't know that
concept but I know now looking back a
lot of these guys I was not hanging with
but I mean I was exposing myself to
their business principles like bunker
hunt and and who was part of the
billionaire Hunt Brothers and it was
quite quite interesting now we have a
special bonus clip from Dan on how to
step up that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing question let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one which
three successful people will you model
this week number two where do you need
to focus on making
or money number three what failure will
you not let stop you and if you promise
to take action after watching this video
we don't just watch videos anymore we do
something after watching them
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work most of the people
managing money wealth today have never
seen a bad market they went around in 87
I have but all the guys that have are
dead got dementia are not interested
anymore there are going to be more
opportunities when everything falls this
but it takes it takes balls I mean you
got to step in and you may have to put
your whole net worth on the line and
then because you stopped playing to win
and you start playing not to lose I've
been there if you want more Dane pina
check out the last top fifty I mean him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there this is
what I'm training you to be like the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse Adolf
Hitler might be the highest performance
guy that ever was born